welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode three and I'm about to
speak with Greg o Gallagher Greg is
pretty popular in Toronto specifically
but online in general for his fitness
coaching I think Greg's great he's a
unique individual and the way he sells
his fitness routines and diet routines
online appeals to a very specific type
of audience I'll admit it it probably
wouldn't appeal to me
transformations never did though his
transformations however are absolutely
incredible and a lot of the people he
helps end up healing from health issues
as well
he was preaching about intermittent
fasting in 2011 before it was even close
to mainstream not that it's even
mainstream now and that's another reason
he appeals to me the way he encourages
people to get fed I think is pretty
smart he doesn't focus on health exactly
he focuses on looking a certain way like
a movie star regardless of what people
say this is really what people want they
want to look good it's built in it's
biological it's a lot easier to appeal
to the masses by telling them they can
look a certain way even if what you
should be saying is they can be
healthier fortunately when people get
stronger and leaner they also get
healthier
[Music]
welcome to my podcast I'm happy to be
here just to let to ask you are you are
you currently fasting I am I've had
sparkling water I think we're kind of on
a similar similar regimen do you do the
jail Steiner I've never had that
it's like them it's the most intense
sparkling water I
Oh what about topo Chico that those ones
are good the wheat like the ball eats
like crack open yeah that's my favorite
if I never see them in Canada though
yeah yeah yeah I know they're everywhere
here there's one Whole Foods that's
north of Yorkville that has them okay
mm-hmm just keep that in mind okay so
for people who don't know you I want to
get a bit of your backstory how did you
come to have half a million YouTube
subscribers and fix a whole bunch of
people your Instagram has crazy
transformations on it like where did you
start where are you from who are you
yeah well I was one of those kids where
you know you don't think about like a 13
14 year old working out and doing
push-ups and chin-ups and curls and and
having that you know burning desire to
you know get stronger etc but that was
me I just was fascinated by the idea
that we can we can transform our body
and I just remember like being a young
kid I was like I can't wait to hit the
gym like you know how you know in your
little kid your parents like no wait
till you're 16 to lift weights I was
like don't want to go right now
oh I couldn't wait till I get stronger
and bigger and and it was one of those
things where when I was you know 14 15
16 I was like wait a second we're
learning about like careers and high
school and everything I'm like wait I
can do fitness for a career I'm like
that's amazing I'm like that's what I'm
gonna do and I started kind of working
some gyms and personal training when I
was like you know 17 18 and it wasn't
you know it wasn't quite fulfilling
enough am i hmm this isn't like training
clients isn't you know it's cool but it
doesn't feel like I'm waking up every
day to you know accomplish my dreams it
just feels like I'm waking up to you
know training
and taking through workouts and that's
when I really started to you know I was
like I was like what am i doing all day
I'm like all I'm doing is like reading
these different fitness experts reading
their blogs buying their workout courses
I'm like well why don't I do that and I
got a mentor and I started like I
started blogging and and and the angle
that I really really connect that really
I connected to was kind of building that
Hollywood physique because a lot of
people talking about bodybuilding
putting on you know 30 40 pounds
training for sports endurance training
running etc and I was like well what do
I really want I'm not an athlete I don't
care about getting massive I'm like well
I just want to be strong and functional
and look like a movie star and that was
the angle that I wanted and sure enough
that's what everyone else wanted like I
said I started writing about you know
Ryan and what was that one of the ways I
got I built my following was I was
writing about celebrity workout articles
because they had a lot of search volume
but very little competition so I would
be like hey guys like here is what I
would do to get this sort of body text
and Crazy Stupid Love with Ryan Gosling
and here's here my client results and
that sneaky yeah it was you know quite
the finesse and nobody very quickly I
started ranking and tons of traffic and
and I started sharing these workouts I
was like let me just give value let me
just help as many people as I can
yeah and like you think like writing a
free workout online people just gonna
read a bit oh cool and then like maybe
we do one workout and then never do it
again I was getting transformations and
testimonials from my free blog articles
people hey dude I was doing you're like
you're Daniel Craig workout for two
months and I best work I've ever done in
my life you should make a whole program
and so everything kind of happened like
or get is it was very much like me
communicating with my audience I would
even before is making money I would
spend like five hours a day like answer
people's emails and helping them out and
so it's so in touch with my audience
that everything kind of just fell into
place
and that was really how I started but um
things really blew up when I was like
maybe I should do some YouTube videos
and I was like well and and and at that
point I'd already written hundreds of
articles on fitness so when I turned on
the camera I was just I knew what to say
and I and the YouTube the YouTube
Fitness was pretty much plagued with a
lot of back in the day was like the bro
science people would be spouting
espousing myths that weren't true
you have to eat every two to three hours
your body can only have 30 grams of
protein at a time and when is back in
the day for me so you know what year is
this well I kind of splashed into the
fitness scene in 2011 and I started
really talking about internet fasting
like pretty much 2012 and at that point
like people like whoa in a minute
fasting yeah that's the worst thing you
can do so very few people if I was out
if I was out at a restaurant and holy
crap you're eating LA but yeah I'm doing
fasting really well that's not like
everyone would be like that's the worst
thing you can do but I just owned it I
was like it's pretty freaking get great
and how did you figure that out because
that was way before people started like
it that it got popular at all today just
like was that just self testing or what
well so ultimately it was important that
I had a frame like a goal that I wanted
to achieve the first thing was I had I
had this goal I was like damn I want it
you know I'm good at gaining strength
and muscle at gym but I'm having this
hard time getting to that level of
definition where I look really really
good like that's you know what your
physique pops and I was like so
everything I was doing was testing
things to achieve that low body fat and
I'm the worst dieter in the world
nobody's worse than me I am brutal I
failed every diet I tried I couldn't
stick with it the small little meals
it's like you know it's just a matter of
time before I'd fall off the wagon and
eat a box and cookies that was me and
and I was like man this this stuff isn't
working I'm like I can't you know like
this getting ripped and eating five six
meals or cutting a car like you know I
like doing all this stuff was tricky for
me and and then what really
stuck with me is one of the guys that
was falling I gotta give credit where
credit's due is rusty more and he you
know he had a fitness blog and he had
some really cool interesting content and
one of the things he talked about was
fasting and a great strategy to get lean
it's like once or twice a week to a
24-hour fast and he pointed to this book
called each stop beat by Brad peel on
and I checked out
I checked out I checked out his book and
yet he he's basically did he went to
university of guelph in Canada and he
did his master did his thesis his paper
on him on in a minute fasting to show
that it's not good for for you know it's
not good for your physique it's not good
for health it's not good for it's not
optimal for building muscle losing fat
etc and then it turned out that
everything he thought he knew was he was
wrong and he went through all this
research I started to realize that
there's amazing benefits for fasting
you're not gonna um you know you're not
gonna you know you're not gonna lose
muscle if you're doing like a short-term
you know 2 P 24 even 72 hours you just
went through all the research is like
fat mobilization is up a lot of the
changes that happen when you work out
hormonal II actually happen when you
fast in some limited low growth someone
goes up etc if fat mobilization kicks in
and so he started you know talking about
fasting and I was like this is really
interesting the way he was framing it
was basically doing once or twice a week
200 24-hour fast and I liked it but I'm
like I need a daily routine to stick to
because if I can do it fast once a week
but I need to get like I need to get my
stuff dialed in on the other days and
sometimes just kind of eating breakfast
you start to get into snacky mode and
you know Sammy I am way more because I
have I'm Way sharper when I just fast
every day and so I started reading
there's also another guy I'm or HOF met
where he wrote the book called the
warrior diet I think he wrote that like
before before 2011 mid mid 2000s and
then there's another figure
Martin Birkin who was kind of you know
more of like that bodybuilder intense
like he like helped coach people for
fitness competitions and
get a very dialed in form of fasting
that he was doing and teaching and so I
kind of learned from all these different
figures and sort of put together really
the strategy that I'm like that is just
absolutely you know downright enjoyable
gets the job done and so I kind of put
together like really the way that I love
to do fasting that it's just super easy
to follow and you know supports your
goals so that's kind of how I got into
fasting 2011 and the final thing I was
gonna say there is that you know when I
started sharing articles on fasting and
YouTube videos I was like man I don't
know if people are even gonna know
people might backlash this keyboard
might not connect but for me it's I I
just want to share what I love doing
what works for me that's all I want to
do if I love something gonna share it if
I'm not doing something I'm not sharing
it I'm only sharing what I do and so I
was like I gotta tell people about
fasting and and people were like huh
like funny enough make my audience like
I started carve-out years ago they were
that type of audience that like just
that kind of doesn't necessarily want to
just agree with the mainstream they want
to learn and test and apply that's like
ultimately my like main like message is
that like don't just take what I say as
the voice of God test it put to the test
get your own gets your own experience
from it and people were like hope people
were just loving fasting it was insane
it wasn't like one out of three one out
of four people it was like everyone was
doing this weird like like the just holy
like I'm never like I I've never been
able to lean down so much easier even I
had even my own brother was overweight
and he started fasting at like 16 years
old
and he just you know he always struggled
and then just one start fasting he's
losing a pound a week found a week pound
a week
pound a week and then he was like one
summer he's just like whoa [ __ ] you look
good so a lot of people that suck at
dieting like me and you know fasting is
like that switch it's like that thing
where you like it just and then you can
eat these big meals and you feel like
you're not dieting and you're in the
deficit or whatever and so yeah so
that's how I that's my story on fasting
cool that's very cool I didn't get into
it along with no no that's good that's
really cool and you've been at this for
like a long time so that's fun most of
the people I know who are super into
fasting it's been like the last really
two years probably God said it's just
not more popular in the last couple
years it's like weird because 2011 is
when I first started and then 2012 like
like 2012 till now man I don't even
think I've had breakfast more than a few
times
Wow I wish I had taken it out earlier
yeah I was you know I kind of was you
know I was doing my I kind of I kind of
fell across the right you know the right
pass and and and then just I just loved
it I was like this is so this is that
like this it doesn't like I would do
this like no matter what I didn't want
to even if I could be breakfast and it
wouldn't even count the calories in
khammam I don't want it I like feeling
fat like I like in that fasted State
yeah yeah I feel that I like that so
what does in that case cuz you're not on
a diet you're on you do intermittent
fasting strictly what does a typical day
of eating look like for you and like how
many calories you count calories right
yeah but you know what I kind of eyeball
it you know I don't like to be like
having the tracking everything sometimes
get too neurotic about track and
everything is like the pleats are
willpower and then you're more likely to
mess up yeah so yeah I so basically the
framework that I set my diet up in is
alright for me to get lean you know I
gotta hit this many calories this many
this much protein and that's really what
I focus on get your calories in get your
protein you need to have sufficient
protein and maintain muscle and the
calorie deficit will will dictate the
fat loss or you know the muscle gain if
you're gonna calorie surplus and I just
basically eat the foods that make that
make that as easy as possible for me so
I will fast literally till I wake up a
bit later I'm up at 11 12 I will fast
and have like a my first sort of light
meal around 5:00 but from
people that would be a bit earlier and
that might be I'll mix up just something
light to tie me over I've been having
like a collagen protein shake banana
sometime a few eggs sometimes I'll
literally have a Starbucks rice krispie
square which sounds crazy I'm telling
you these 250 calories yeah I'm like I'm
like hot it's like they get staves off
my hunger basa that first meal just get
some like get some calories and just
Steve off my hunger and if I could just
fast without even doing that sometimes
I'll just fast till till my big but
again it's really it's really for me
it's really finding something that that
um I can eat in that first light meal
where I am it doesn't open those
floodgates and you want to go on you
know you want to keep eating so I just
you know I'll eat something light and
then I'll do a big feast around
dinnertime and that's where you know I
all do a probably about 1400 calories so
I'll do like a huge portion I like a 16
ounce New York Strip we've been doing
the same yeah we got the same state guy
yeah and then I will I will do like a
pound of potatoes and with some butter
and that's like my big feast and then
typically I mix it up at that site yeah
I've had to sum it down to like what it
is it's like a pound of steak a pound of
potatoes and butter and everything and
then and then I'll always save like
literally like this and again I I like
I'm the worst dieter so the way I set my
diet up is like so I can stick to it and
be in the calorie deficit and so that I
always fought I find that when I saved
the last 500 calories for chocolate I'm
really good at the calorie deficit you
know so I always like I'm not even
kidding like every night like chocolate
almond bar my last 500 calories and it
you know I you sometimes you know I
finished my last meal and I still have
this impulse to eat a little bit more to
you know have a craving here and there
and so every you know once over 84 days
or three days I could go over and I'm
like damn I'm not getting laid I'm like
just eat the chocolate you're gonna need
and you're gonna get ripped and so but
ultimately like what I tell people is
like look all i care is that you hit
your calories you hit your protein and
we set the diet up in a way that you can
stick to that you enjoy it that you love
it and then if for you that's finishing
off with a chocolate bar and that helps
you hit your deficit then that's what
we're gonna do if it's you know and and
I'm open to it you know I'm open to
people that that I'm gonna like my thing
is like I want to just do whatever is
gonna work the best for you so if
someone wants to go lower card great
let's go lower card but let's get your
calories and let's hit your protein if
someone wants to be vegan I'm like okay
you can do that like my I just want to
get you Rip's whatever you know so as
long as you follow the levers that I
focus on that's what matters and there's
flexibility there but I found for me
like state potatoes and chocolate is
like where it's like honestly that
doesn't even sound like too bad of a
diet like hell I know you're saying
you're not on a diet but compared to
like only eating pizza do you think you
could get the results you are looking
for if you just hit the right number of
calories but switch your steak and
potato meal / - pizza so and this is
where like the calorie deficit is like
that equalizer because I wouldn't be as
full on the uneaten pizza you know and
so there's this tendency to eat to eat
more but me I I think steak is the
greatest thing in the world you know I
think that yeah I probably eat seven
eight pounds of steak a week every like
I don't even feel the need to like not
eat like I'm like oh my god maybe shutup
chicken so I know I'm down for steak
every night yeah I feel that yes I you
know and and so I think that definitely
I like the fact like steak is super high
and micronutrients like when I eat steak
I just feel great and so ya know the
diet's pretty solid that's the thing is
that like you know sometimes people will
freak out about oh my god saturated fat
or cholesterol it's like you know the to
really maintain great house you know
there's a you know there's there's some
people like some things get a bad rep
because they'll go on and they look at
someone that is inactive overweight you
know
smoker acceptor drinking tons of sodas
and they're gonna be like oh this person
has poor health and you're eating
they're eating saturated fat cholesterol
I've had clients that literally are yeah
40 pounds overweight that start fasting
that HIPPA deficit that are eating steak
and chocolate and their health markers
improve massively I can get behind that
okay oh I have quite so I asked my
Instagram questions to ask you and I got
a whole bunch of them so we're gonna get
into that but first I'm gonna ask you
the questions I want answered and one of
them I know you've been experimenting
with micro dosing because I've seen that
on your Instagram so I've wondered like
have you noticed any from things from
that what have you been using it for are
you still doing it yeah okay so yes I
kind of first did mushrooms like I think
almost two years ago and it was such a
beautiful experience I'm like oh my god
this is amazing everyone needs to
everyone needs to experience this how
many how many do you take the first time
I did it I think I did it just over gram
1.2 grams I think one point yeah and I
was just unbelievable and just something
that kind of something I I kind of just
played around with I didn't I'd never
like I didn't go like full like let's go
to my mic would like let's do Co micros
I kind of actually more so gravitate
towards like you want to get Graham and
for me it was like okay yeah for me for
me it was like you know I can it felt
like you know in life you got so many
things going on your play you're all
these balancing things for me was like
turning off the computer just doing a
full-on reset and that's how I felt I
was like well I feel like just all this
weight is off and I feel so good and
it's just like it gets you out of your
paradigm the way you see the world the
lens you're looking through life with it
takes you out of there you can see
things from from new perspectives and
for people listening like doing it
grandma mushrooms not it's not a lot I
don't really I don't trip out or
hallucinate I just feel really good
that's it I just felt like wow I feel so
good and then
you just you know your heart is open you
blast open your heart chakra and
actually you know there was a point in
time when I was doing mushrooms twice a
week that's probably a little bit too
much be honest but it was weird because
I was strength training and I was the
one of the lean bulking so I was heavier
but I just remember this feeling
invincible in the gym I'm like you know
usually you know every three weeks once
you're advanced you hit this plateau on
an exercise you got three weeks of oh I
added a rep oh I added five pounds and
then I added a rep and then oh it's like
when I said mush as twice a week I was
like there was like there wasn't really
I don't know I can't say we're gonna try
to doubt but I'm like something was
going on with those mushrooms because I
wasn't hitting any PRS and I know all my
variables and track everything I'm like
hmm like hmm like I don't know my
philosophy is that you know it's
mushrooms is literally like a full-body
reset and you just get amazing recovery
your nervous systems fully recharged and
that's one of the that's one of the
things that happen when you um when
you're hitting plateaus and the gym is
is it it's not necessarily your it's not
necessarily always just your muscles are
fatigued your muscles haven't adapted
and built its your nervous system is a
limiting factor your nervous system is
the powerhouse that recruits your muscle
into action and when you see guys that
lift a lot of weight but they're not too
big like they're lean and like well that
guys lifting weight way more weight than
I would expect he's got a very strong
nervous system but when you train
intensely week after week month after
month year after year you know that
nervous system can become fatigued and
this is especially true when you're
doing like a Stang yeah when you're
doing like exercises that if you do it
see here's the thing if you do an
exercise that you've never done before
it's like you can do your you know your
very fresh but the longer you've worked
in an exercise longer you've been trying
to you know do this exercise for the
more takes out of you which is why I
have my clients kind of do some rotation
we're even even right now my clients we
like we did up we're doing a bodyweight
program 3 to 12 weeks because all the
gyms are shut down and yeah
yeah it's um body weight training it's
like well I feel so fresh and everything
well yeah that's like that's like the
other nerve I don't know I'd like to see
like to see someone talking about this
is is how yeah mushrooms affect your
your CNS recovery yeah no that's really
interesting I'm a huge fan of mushrooms
I think they're extremely beneficial or
clearly you know I wouldn't even be
surprised like I'd full-on believe that
was possible with it like when I first
started doing much as I loved it so much
I probably went a little bit too far but
you know I think that for people
listening that they're like like
interested it's like honestly it is a
beautiful experience but yeah maybe yeah
do the do the micro dose to do quarter
gram half grand quarter gram yeah even
one gram that's it's not gonna be too
it's not and I've had I know a lot of
people that never did mushrooms and then
like they're doing mushrooms we had them
do mushrooms together and like I can't
tell you one example where someone was
like I did not like that I was like that
was the best thing ever oh my god I
never did it but ideally wait till like
you're 25 you know I wouldn't I wouldn't
be going to doing mushrooms if you're 19
years old when he's fair yeah when I
started I was um 16 me and then told me
to say that until you're 25
no 16 was the first time but I didn't do
like a large a large amount until I was
19 and then I did a large amount and
that was like I've had a couple of trips
that with larger amounts that have been
like iffy but even if those words I
there's a sense of calm like there still
seem to be benefits even after truths
that aren't great so after that's
interesting yeah yeah and my body feels
better like that's something interesting
I've noticed because I've got two joints
replaced which isn't ideal for just
overall comfort
and I feel my muscles loosen up more so
I don't know what that's about but no I
feel I enjoy it I feel that 100%
yeah say about mushrooms is that like
you know it it forces you into this
really beautiful state where it's good
to learn from because typically human
beings we got a million things going on
we think about this or think about that
where I can email a chicken this chicken
social media
we're not present very people you know
yeah very few people present for
freaking even it's 15 minutes straight
and I still need to work at this I used
to like really get into meditation I was
like present all the time and I felt so
good but mushrooms naturally shifts you
in that state where you're just so
present you know you don't care about
well it's good to for people with
social-media followings and things it's
so easy to get wrapped up in that and
stuck on the internet and when you're on
mushrooms you do not care at all you
don't you don't it's not imagine doing
the most advanced meditation of your
life with some crazy dude for ten hours
that's what like mushrooms feels like
yeah so yeah that's it is cool you get
really really present and yes humans are
happier when were present yeah I agree
I've been trying to cut down on social
media but it's hard I'm always trying to
cut down on social media yeah me too I
took one day off and then I crazy I saw
that 24 hour up 24 hours off that's a
lot I haven't done that I haven't done
that in I don't know how long so you
know what though I needed it I just kind
of you know yeah it's rough you you get
flack to you get a lot of flack people
are jealous no telling you you know
you're on drugs other than shrooms and
it's [ __ ] that's that's what you know
when you're not sure when you're getting
people ripped and and this is like this
is the this is what everyone wants every
guy that works out that's natural wants
to be accused of steroids because
proof that you just [ __ ] kill ya so
I'm like am i oh [ __ ] oh cool you know
I'm not if I'm not then you know I'm not
I'm not I'm not doing I'm not doing my
that's a very good way to think about it
actually yeah no I know it's true I mean
I remember being like annoyed and
frustrated like [ __ ] like I just put in
all this work and I build this body and
now people because I just taking it away
and then you know one of my friends
actually you know the guy that wrote the
book eat sabe we're connected and I was
I was like [ __ ] pissed man he's like
dude I would love to get ya get those
accusations dude that's the sign you're
killing it but that's just like a small
that's like just like a small subset
then you know what when you put yourself
out there for anyone you know you're
gonna you're always gonna get you know
you're always gonna get haters or
negative feedback but the main thing to
focus on is the people that you're
helping and the people that yeah for you
and follow you and don't don't focus on
the people that why would you focus on
them you know like it's like you know
you're your brand your presence it's
like your frickin party and you want the
right people in it you don't be throwing
in so forget about them yeah and that's
what I really like to about your
Instagram page is all those
transformations you post up like that's
completely changed somebody's life and a
lot of those people have health issues
too especially if they're carrying
around extra weight like that comes with
health issues a lot of the time and then
you're giving them something extremely
beneficial that totally transforms like
their everyday that's so awesome so I'm
a fan thank you you know what yeah
that's yeah that's that's like the one
thing you know in the fitness ball all
these you know other guys selling you
know workout burgers and everything
that's like you know they're not I'm not
seeing their transformations or not
seeing crazy transformations and I'm
like yeah with the way I teach thanks
people just stick to it and they just
get stronger and leaner and they're
remarkable sometimes like sometimes I'll
get I'll get transformations people
telling me like literally they were
suicidal and they're you know I don't
you know this is just what they're
telling me you know but but it's like
it's just they're they're basically they
were
not happy in life and they lost control
they lost purpose and everything was
going wrong and then they just got that
little glimmer of hope like let's
finally do this you know body think damn
it he just jumped up on an ad he seems
like it's pretty [ __ ] great so let's
just try this program and they'll
[ __ ] do it like and then they get you
know what it is that they get hooked
about they get talked about going to the
gym you know we're working out three
days a week and this I had in those five
pounds because that's what my systems
focused on it's every workout there's
our goal we're getting a little stronger
adding a little rep here maybe now on
month three we're adding it in this
extra four so this is always this goal
to focus on that's what people need in
life they need bingi small achievable
goals small this you know small
achievable goal you know sometimes in
life especially when you're younger
you're 19 young there's so few things
you have control over that having that
control over something where you can
work on it and improve upon it and you
see the changes and you feel empowered
and you build that self belief it just
ripples across everything cool that's
probably something I need to change up a
little bit on because you know what I'm
telling I'm trying to work on something
like an autoimmune disorder and the step
from going from eat whatever you want to
just eat beef even if it is steak which
is great is really really difficult
yeah and I mean the only reason I could
do it was because the alternative was
like hell it wasn't easy so there's no
achievable steps that's important yeah
you know what actually that makes sense
because if your symptoms with autoimmune
disorder if you eat XYZ food or whatever
are so severe that it's just like the
mathematical equation of okay let me eat
this piece of bread and feel sick for
seven days and have no energy and be
miserable and have a life not worth
living or don't eat the bread and just
enjoy my steak its I feel good like
obviously there but some people their
symptoms might be a little more subtle
yeah so it's a lot harder for them but
yeah I've had people ask me to and like
how did you do it and it was like it you
would have done it
you felt as [ __ ] as I did yeah wasn't
that hard
what do you think the small achievable
stuff would be for someone that's you
know they benefit from you know the
foods but yeah I'd pro you know what I
do actually is I usually tell people if
you're really not really willing to
change things the least you could do is
try going gluten-free like for people
with what I did yeah so that's the first
one is just do that and that's really
not hard nowadays too because you can
basically just replace everything that
has gluten with something gluten free so
that's the first step and then if they
want to do something bigger I say try
and go grain free so though I guess
those are the small achievable that's
that's what I do and you know what
actually I was also you know the thing
that the thing that I think also is
helpful at least for me is that it's
that the idea of if you come like for me
it's like if I was to combine that
because like when you just focused on
the foods and everything it's like
there's this missing element of like you
know like for me it's like if I if I add
the calories and the protein to the
equation which sounds like silly but
it's like I didn't actually I'm like I
now II want to find the most enjoyable
way to to to eat and so I'm like well
man like you know if I want to go eat
all this bread and pasta I'm like is
that gonna make it harder to hit my
calorie deficit your parrot to eating so
I find like when I control for getting
rips and hitting the calories in the
deficit I'm like my temptation for other
foods and everything go with the window
cuz all about how do i structure this
end so it could be some people or if
they if they are having a hard time you
know excluding it's like you know what
let's just let's also get you fit what's
your goal okay you wanna lose ten pounds
all right so now you're gonna be doing
this would make you know and here's your
meat and like to see how it easy it is
and enjoyable it is to eat all this meat
every day and just lean down because you
know it's meats very filming etc yeah so
maybe if they combine it with like
looking better and then hitting they're
you know meat and then they see how oh
my god I'm so Wow like it so easy yeah
then it
might be extra motivation and that
certainly helps like most of the people
who are like most of the people who
gravitate toward the carnivore diet most
of them are doing it for health reasons
but they do end up losing weight just
because they end up eating more meat and
getting fuller off of that and that's a
huge motivator so yes I completely agree
ok I'm going to the next question this
is still my question I haven't even
gotten to any answers ok good good luck
actually yeah ok ok so have a couple
what your focus is make people look
attractive which is a great focus
because that's what people try and do
for themselves in order to mate with
other people that's literally what
humans do so if you had to pick like two
or three no not work outs but just like
I'm so not in the workout sphere it's
unbelievable but safe for women they
want to focus I'm assuming on like booty
building which is really popular on
Instagram so what would like a few
exercise exercises be for that I'm Lily
just finishing up my latest woman's
program launch in a couple weeks but
absolutely so for women I would say it's
basically you know for whether you're a
guy or girl basically all the concepts
hold true if you're a guy that wants to
gain muscle or lose fat same for women
but women are typically if you you know
they want it crafted they want to focus
on yet being lean fat toned and building
a great booty so the way I focus on
improving your body is by getting
stronger if you want to build and create
a great but you can be doing all these
exercises there's all these circuits and
burpees and everything and it's all
pish-posh
the only thing that matters is that when
you go and you do that and you started
doing your squat with a which is
bodyweight for 10 reps then now we're
doing it with 20 pounds for 10 reps and
now we're going up to 25 pounds and when
we do your walking lunges or etc or hit
we're adding a rap we're adding five
pounds of people get so focused on doing
a million exercises being in the gym
every day doing XY and z doing circuits
oh I thought I had such a good work at
home like I'm sore did you get stronger
you're still lifting the same weight
doing the same reps so how is it that
you think your body is changing
and so sometimes most funny enough you
think that most workout programs we
focused on the progressive overload
factor which is the driver of progress
of gaining muscle but it's funny enough
they're not so I would say for women
there's a handful of exercises that are
really effective and really good at
hitting your glutes and that's what you
want to focus on and you can live where
you can see results working out once a
week but ideally you'd hit your lower
body twice a week Monday Friday and the
exercises that are really good are so
hip thrusts obviously you can that
basically is the essential role of your
glutes which is hip extension driving
your hips forward so hip thrusts are
great forward lunges have been shown to
really activate the glutes um really
really well and that's we do big step
forward and then you lunge back but
there is a factor where you need to
teach yourself how to use your glutes a
lot of people are quad dominant and
they'll do in any exercise and they'll
find a way to use their quads you want
to get rid of that I was lucky because I
played hockey ball I'm Canadian so
obviously yeah he kind of teaches you
how to you know that you're skating
you're getting a lot of that glute Drive
it kind of teaches you how to activate
your glutes that's why you know hockey
players in their own having like strong
glutes but so you want to learn how to
activate your glutes when you train when
you're doing squats when you're doing
lunges etc and that kind of really
focuses you know the key there is if you
do want to squat go wider widen up the
closer you go the more quads the why do
you go the more glutes try and sit back
on the heels don't just let your knees
come forward
sit back it helps to even do squats on
to a box to really teach you how to sit
back so I say for people that want to
build their glutes we're gonna build
look better it's like first you know
start to master these exercises and do
so in a way we're like wow I really feel
my glutes working in it it even you know
I like doing lower reps but even in the
beginning it's good to do high reps
because you can really build that
mind-muscle connection and and so yeah I
would say you know for lunges take a
bigger step to really hit your glutes
even side lunges you know hip thrusts
you can even do Bulgarian split squat
your amazing exercise and you can really
focus on coming straight down my new
programs gonna be kind of basically
built around a lot of these exercises
and consistently getting stronger step
ups are great for the glutes but you
know simple workout a you know Romanian
deadlifts or deadlift variation that are
is more hip dominant really really
effective but a lot of girls will get
caught up in like they'll go on you know
they'll go on the mats they'll pick up
their legs up and down
do these cables and do these things and
it's not the most effective way
to change your panties thing that's
that's good yeah that's good to know the
mind the mind-body connection to I had
issues like well I have issues obviously
but like with my hip in particular
building glutes because of the hip
replacement
I'm extremely quad dominant and I didn't
even know until maybe last year that I
wasn't activating my glutes until I went
to a physio who knew what they were
doing and they're like you're doing hip
thrusts but you're like you're using
your back or something I wasn't anyway
that is important it is important to
like just connect and make sure you're
actually activating the right muscle and
you know there's a great thing you do
before every workout do it every day and
it's just lie on your back have your
feet flat on the ground ground like
you'd like to do a sit-up but don't do a
sit-up just drop push drive your heels
on the ground lift your pelvis up it's
called the glute bridge hold it and just
focus on squeezing your glutes you can
put your hands on your on your legs and
and just squeeze that hold it for 30
seconds and if you want to make things
even more fun as you hold it keep your
keep your pelvis as high as you can and
then drive your knee to your chest and
then go back and drive the other knee
it's called the glute March essentially
most people have a really hard time
activate the glutes but starting your
workout off with that it helps turn
things on so that now when you go and do
a lunge you feel it in your glutes but
that's like the one thing you know when
I talk good tip yeah the glute bridge
and the glute March every day and and
really you can even if you have if you
put even if you're doing it and you put
your finger on your booty it helps you
activate it so I would recommend that
because a lot of women you know and for
me it's like if I'm building my physique
I set up my training and I set up the
exercises in a way to build the
proportion that I want the physique on
right now it's not by accident so I just
mean getting stronger than gym lifting
weights it's the way I craft the
training and the same thing for women
and some things that women don't want is
like well I want to build my booty but I
don't want my quads to go up two inches
yeah and so it's like well okay well if
you're doing all the exercises and
you're using your quads and you're not
well you're not gonna achieve that
proportion that look you want so the
first thing is let's teach you how to
activate your glutes and that's how your
body's actually design and meant to you
know really use those use the glutes
you're much stronger and more effective
that's why some of the best athletes in
the world they have you know they're
very hip dominant they have very strong
powerful glutes mm-hmm okay great well
then your unless any issues too if
you're always using quads and quad
dominant you can be hard on the knees
mm-hmm that's cool okay well I want to
try your new program no I'm actually
gonna be I'm doing my time doing the
woman's program too and starting next
week I got to do this I'm taking my
booty you know that's awesome
okay what about for men like what's
what's the attractive what is it that
makes men look attractive it's the
v-shape right it's the v-shape but
there's another factor to it and the V
shapes the first aspect on the shoulder
to waist ratio there's actually it's
pretty interesting it's supposedly the
shoulder waist ratio is the strongest
sign of physical attraction in men
so more lean height more yeah yeah it's
five seconds yeah okay I can see that I
can see that yeah it's that shoulder
waist ratio that's you know you you know
you can do your own research there but
that's kind of what keeps popping up in
some of these research studies is it's
the first thing is that and it makes
sense I mean if someone was shaped like
a pyramid and six-foot-two I mean it's
not necessarily the most desirable log
versus a guy that's five nine but just
looks like a Greek statue yeah so the
shoulder weights and that basically is a
maintaining a low body fat so being lean
you don't have to be seven seventy
percent you have to have ripped abs but
having a slim waist and then secondly
you know building up those muscle groups
that improve your V shape so that's
gonna be your chest your back your
shoulders and that V shape really is
what you want to strive for but to
really like create that captivating look
where you just it just has like a level
of a portion that you don't really see
too often
um what you want to do is you want to
really focus on the upper chest that
gives your chest a plate of armor look
if you go in the gym you sees guys with
puffy pecs and you're like kind of looks
like this guy's got freaking big tits
you don't want that but let me set just
should fly you know Marmot like holy
Shih this guy looks like he's wearing
like a frickin literally plate of armor
chest like steel
that's like focusing very much on the
upper chest and so a lot yeah a lot of
incline press the shoulders are you know
very important to focus on shoulder
pressing lateral raises to build you
know those rounded shoulders when you
see a lot of times you go to the gym you
see guys with big chest big arms but
they're the last shoulder isn't just
it's not you know it's not really you
know this fictional there's signal
strength and masculinity and lately I've
been getting more into like training the
traps because you'll see people you'll
see guys that focus you know but maybe
even have good shoulders two-inch and
chest and you're looking at them and
you're like something looks weird here
they have upper bodies but like their
neck or sort they're like they're
missing this size right here and it just
feels flat and so it feels like kind of
their head is attached to their body and
so like having if you look at a lot of
movies or actors get in shape like even
James McAvoy when you played the beast
some of those films or or Tom Hardy some
of the even Chris Hemsworth they won't
like they they find like these actors
they train their traps so it makes them
look more jacked and imposing yeah
because in America
definitely Captain America if you're
looking at if you're looking at even me
right now this is like how it would have
a conversation you notice everything
that's up here like when you look at my
face you notice these areas and so if
you add this a little bit muscle to your
traps you look more jacked so I would
say you know traps upper chest shoulders
and yes a lot of pull-ups to get that
good v-shape
come on but you know it's like you you
want to be you know you got to be
balanced you got to work out everything
you got to build you know portion great
legs too so but those are really those
are the areas we want to focus a little
bit more on
so as you gain muscle you start to
create that look that you want
cool that's all helpful information okay
I'm gonna get to some audience questions
because there are some fun ones okay
well this one isn't that much fun but
people are a couple of people were
worried about energy levels at such a
low body fat percentage so what body fat
percentage are you at currently okay so
I the last time I did the DEXA scan is
it clinic here in Toronto and the DEXA
is one of the most accurate ways to
measure your body fat so do x-ray scan
and it tells you how much fat you have
in every part of your body torso legs
muscle bone you know your bone mass and
so last time I did it I was six point
one percent which is low Wow what I'm
like yeah I'm like I'm that was I'm like
leaner now so be cut down so I've like
I'm like legit a pound a half two pounds
of body fat not weight body fat leaner
which would put me closer to five
percent on a deck set but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the DEXA can be
off by a couple percent so but point
being is that my yeah my body fat is
pretty low and right now and so the
question was like energy and everything
yeah I was like especially fasting
people are worried about one if you skip
breakfast you get less energy and you -
I have such a low body fat percentage
yeah yeah you're fatigued or anything
yeah so the the breakfast thing is that
was the case of missing skipping
breakfast you have low energy I don't
even think our humans would have gotten
here now because we didn't need we
weren't even weird we were you know in a
hunter-gatherer days we didn't have you
know a fridge to open up or cupboards to
open up with all these packaged foods
and everything to eat we were we were
fasting and foraging and sometimes we'd
have to go you know just like you go 72
hours without food yeah our energy and
that and that was the time when you had
to be at your sharpest you have an even
two days if your energy is down and your
mental focus and sharpness falls apart
how the heck are you gonna are you gonna
catch
how the heck are you gonna you know find
some food yeah so yeah you actually get
you should try I would you get you a
total highs to the longer you go like I
think the longest I've done is eight
days you would not be able to because
you have like no body fat and you need
body fat in order to do the extended
fast but like wow it was my eyes sharp
my my eyes were sharp my mind was more
clear my sense of smell was off the
charts like I could this got really
weird I could smell people when I was
walking down the street oh like I could
smell people I was just like this is wow
you know more than animal and you what
power mark was that things like changed
for you now that I've been doing fasting
more probably things don't really get
intense until around 48 hours like it
used to be earlier it used to be 36 and
then I got more used to it so now 48 but
around 72 things get really cool yes my
you know I wanted to test around doing a
longer fast at some point for those
reasons but nonetheless I can smell
people very distinctively but I have a
hard time sleeping if I haven't eaten
that night
if you drastically increase your salt
before you go to bed and I mean
drastically like a gram of salt and like
300 grams of potassium before you go to
sleep you should be able to get rid of
that like really the first time the
first time I did an extended fast
I didn't sleep and do you know have you
heard of Jason Fung yeah so his thoughts
are because your adrenaline increases
you don't actually need as much sleep so
don't worry about it if you're not tired
you're not tired but I've found that if
you like drastically increase salt
especially before you go to bed you can
completely get rid of that like wired
feeling so I'll test that I didn't mean
to do I even add some sodium tonight I
was even just throwing in some salt in
your water and like you're even during
the fast yeah it's way easier yeah I
have a lot of sodium
and potassium during my fast yeah it's
actually the funny thing is there's so
many magically oh my god you're not
eating salt it's like dude people think
I can't salt like come on it's if you do
if you if you didn't get any salt you
would die but you know they have trade
salts and foods and everything but oh
yes so the energy thing at a low body
fat is also the whole to salt like you
know maintaining a sex drive and low
body fat it is it is something that
contests bodybuilders and everything
struggle with when they when they get
soso lead I would say right now I'm a
little bit leaner than I should maintain
and you know if everyone's listening
right now or guys are watching the video
podcasts like um you know you if you
look on my Instagram and see some of the
latest content like that's the kind of
leanness where you don't see too many
people maintain that year-round they'll
get in shape for that for a shoot
they'll get a shape for that for contact
an but they won't stay there you know
I've been staying this around this
leanness for a long time let's say the
biggest thing is the biggest issue where
people lose their sex drive when they
get lean or they lose their energy is
honestly because they're just losing
weight too fast it's one thing if you
got Twitter 10 or 20 pounds overweight
yeah you know lean down you know you
know you don't need to pace yourself fat
loss is largely the amount of body fat
your you know your body can burn off
it's also dependent on on how much fat
stores you have if you have 40 pounds
again that's not even a crazy amount
that's actually very common you have 40
pounds of body fat on you your body can
handle you know your your body can
handle the bigger calorie deficits your
body is what wants to lose that fat it
wants to get rid of it your leptin
levels which leptin is a hormone that
you know affects your energy levels your
appetite your metabolism when you have
that much body fat you just have tons of
leptin and circling through and you're
you know it's it's the
evenings and bad habits that are getting
you to its this I call it the psychology
psychological factor that's getting you
to overeat but but um yeah when you're
overweight whose weight really fast so
point is is that you get to a point
where you're starting to get lean or
your abs are threatening to pop out and
it's like man trying to lose weight too
quickly that's when things shut down
that's when your body's you know that's
when things so I've coaxed myself to a
very low body fat I've coached myself to
you know and I found it like when you're
getting to lower levels of leanness it's
it's I've used this analogy on a video I
did recently it's kind of feels like
you're surfing sometimes you're just
like you know I just you know I should
just maintain my weight right now maybe
even let my weight come in come up a
couple pounds you can't have to listen
your body and you're basically what
you're doing is just sitting the water
waiting for that next wave to hit and
sometime you kind of have to work with
your body a bit more to get to that
level of leanness and so sometimes I'll
just I'll just go with the flow and then
boom like and then boom like I I'll kind
of doll in the deficit that wave will
come I'll get a few couple pounds few
pounds leaner and they'll stay there
like going from 10 percent to 6 percent
body fat you know people want to be like
ok 10 percent on paper if I lose a 2%
body fat per month then you know I can
get there in 12 weeks yeah yeah no you
can but what is the cost of you to
maintain it so I'm like sometimes my
clients a big dude just now's not the
time you know you're you're you know
just maintain and then you know so I I
think that losing you know when you're
under 10% body fat losing two pounds two
pounds a month is it's pretty good
there's no there's no rush you already
you know your take your time to maintain
it so that's the biggest thing that's
why people they have low energy and and
and and lose their sex drive is because
they are going too extreme or they want
to and I want to get ripped now they're
doing tons of cardio they're cut their
calories more than tons of cardio and
that creates all these problems you have
to look at getting lean as kind of like
look at the numbers all right you know
right now I'm nine percent body fat I
only have this much
bit of fat to lose I only really need to
lose 4 pounds of fat to get to my goal
why would I try and lose those 4 pounds
in just one month when I have so little
such a little fat left let's you know so
I'm burning 2700 calories a day instead
of trying to go to 2,000 or 1,900 let's
just go
2,300 you know and maybe a couple of
times a week I'm gonna eat a little bit
more and so the fat loss is coming
slower but I'm feeling strong in the gym
and X Y Z so that's like where most
people fail but again right now if I was
to be for me to be as optimal as
possible I should not be this way this
is this is just this is just like if I
can this is just me being a little bit
of a nut ball I'm like yeah you know I
like it so I'm like but I should not
stay here for too long it's not you know
it's not like you wake up you see these
veins and your abs and like you know you
see like the muscles in your face
sometimes when you're chewing not all
the time but like you just say like this
no this isn't this should not be here we
should not locked in sometimes just gets
so locked into like you know like you
could probably experienced this when
you're locked into your fasts I've done
that with fasting - yeah yeah you feel
so locked in that you're like man I
don't want to like ease up like I'm like
this is this feels good it feels right
like that there's a sharpness and a
focus you get when you're locked into
your diet whether you're going carnivore
doing fasting or just focus on hitting
your colleague doesn't give it you think
once you're locked in it feels so good
and like those temptations those sways
aren't there and sometimes when you try
and get too relaxed and they go okay you
know I can get in you can fall back to
all to you know more relaxed patterns so
you're when you're locked in yeah it's
nice to kind of maintain it yeah
have you taken just out of curiosity
I've been taking my dad's personality
test yeah myself yeah you know as months
ago my youngest brother Rory he actually
has your dad's t-shirt the the
lock the lobster shirt that is so funny
yeah yeah he's and I've actually you
know when I like my routine I'll watch
at night after I wind up working I'll
watch hours of my favorite way to learn
isn't books I'll watch hours of videos
or podcasts and so yeah I've seen tons
of his content it's awesome but yeah I
end up doing my brother told me about
the person I text the test I did it and
it was really fascinating
what were they because I've been
thinking about this about like people
who try really hard like some of the
things that annoy me about this whole
fitness industry is people look at
people who are really fit and then they
think well that person's lucky right for
something not realizing that it actually
takes a lot of work to look good it
takes a lot of work and some people are
luckier than other people but it still
takes a lot of work so do you think like
the success you've seen is that
something people can really look to
achieve or or are your clients really
motivated people yeah that's a good
question so obviously genetics play a
role obviously you know you get people
at two sides of crane tonight don't
matter it's all about you know it's all
about hard work or no it's all genetics
it's all most answers in life or
somewhere in the middle and and so so
I'll have clients that typically are
fast responders and and it really this
and this is this is I'd say this is
where genetics play the biggest role
it's not necessarily it's more so in how
fast you progress and so I'll have guys
that make amazing transformations in 12
weeks where most people that would take
them closer to six months or seven
months even they just respond so quickly
but it doesn't mean that they can get
light-years further than someone else
that takes a bit longer especially you
know as a natural as a natural like I am
I've been lifting weights since I was 14
and I'm 510 510 in a bit and I'm like
172 so I'm not - I've been working out
literally hitting weight for 14 years
I'm not 200 pounds they're strong limits
but but as far as but so with my
followers like I have I have a lot of
people that just have crazy physique
where we're like in just a year you guys
already look like this that's freaking
amazing it took me longer to get to that
level but but I will I like I I'm pretty
aware self-aware and everything it's
like the level that's trying from the
the strengths that I have and the weight
that I can lift at my weight and the the
body weight the feats of body weight
strength I can do I do have a propensity
to being very strong it's having
relative strength I do have I do have a
gift there I have genetically I'm like
even you know genetically be my family
that were Irish like we're known for
having pretty good upper body strength
so I not everyone that follows me even
if you've been working out for a long
time is gonna be able to like when I was
a bit heavier 185 I did a 315 incline
for two reps which I was about 180 585
pounds of immediate 182 which is just
absurd you'll you'll never see anyone
like guilt that is just absurd you know
absurd strength 225 pounds standing over
and press it like 182 these are these
are levels of strength that are upper
body that are elite and I'm not you know
I'm not dead lifting six seven hundred
pounds or squatting five hundred but my
upper body the strength so I again like
not everyone is gonna get there um but
you don't need to get there like you
don't need to like if I even if I want
to gain muscle my chest do it like the
strength matters the strength matters
immensely but you don't need to lift how
much weight just add a little bit of
muscle to your to your chest so so yes
so in that sense the strength some
people can get there but that's that's
gonna be rare but yeah all my clients
are hitting they're just getting the
craziest PRS and they're hitting they're
getting the fastest progress and like
what like you know incline benching 225
to play so we have some guys that are
doing 275 but there's a genetic
component there but anyone any I don't
care
you are you can get a lien you can get
leaner you can lose fat you can get to
some people like for me actually my
hardest thing was losing fat like I
struggled to diet and said to lean down
and - but but but is more so like
there's more so just you know sticking
to the diet and everything and I'd find
like I was like I other people have such
an easier time eating less I suck at it
and it's kind of two contrasting things
like getting really strong lifting heavy
weight it helps to eat more getting lean
it's like they're kind of in two ways
that caught their contrasting if I want
immense 300 pounds it helps to be
heavier but if I wanna have shredded ABS
I need to be lighter but but so everyone
can get lean everyone can get abs
calorie deficit will get you there with
the right training the right you know
protein and but some people they might
look they might feel and look their best
at 10%
some people might be eight percent most
people it's not gonna even for me I'm
like whatever body fat I am right now
I'm like this isn't this isn't where you
know this isn't necessarily the best
place to maintain but but yeah so Jays
matter but everyone can you know build a
great body
he might you just might not be able to
get to a 315 incline or anything yeah
okay you know I agree and the way you do
it to makes it easier for people like
you know don't you just push your eating
later into the day like still eat what
you want just be smart about it like
yeah yeah and just as a previous point
like I've had clients that would people
would be like all that person's got bad
genetics look at any skinny fat or he's
like oh he's like it's very overweight
this person's got bad genetics and sure
enough those are the people that built
the best bodies sounds crazy but I have
some of these guys that started in just
a war shape and because they're just
their their habits were they were eating
way too much they weren't an act
exercising but once they put the gears
in place their body just transform they
got into crazy shape so again genetics
it's not nestle how good you look doing
nothing it's what
happens when you do things right and how
fast you change yes a hundred percent I
agree okay I'm gonna just ask a few more
questions and then I'll wrap up I need
to remember to ask peeked or to ask you
where people can find you I keep
forgetting that okay okay
for getting a flat stomach do you think
that is diet or is that exercise or is
it both
yeah can you get a flat stomach it's
ultimately it's gonna be diet it's gonna
be I could get someone a flat stomach if
they want to be bedridden all day it's a
deficit it's a calorie deficit you can
cardio and activity can help but what I
tell people to do is is walk walk 10,000
steps a day every day if you want to if
you want to lean down as efficiently as
possible walk 10,000 steps a day it's
about an hour and a half of brisk
walking but everything kind of counts
like you're what I give even those
little bits and pieces throughout your
day and the reason I say walking is
because it helps you stay at a deficit
if you walk if you get 10,000 steps
you're gonna burn you're gonna burn
several hundred calories added to your
you know your resting metabolic rate but
you don't increase your appetite in fact
in many people you actually are less
hungry when you're well funny enough
you're less hungry when you're walking
and you burn those calories it kind of
puts things into place and any it's good
for your mood you feel great you get
outside you're walking and it kind of
just helps your body I would I find it
does and I'm obviously I'm not getting
very scientific here but what I find it
does and in layman's terms is it kind of
helps put your body into the place where
it wants to be when you when you start
walking that much like walking is
actually one of the like greatest things
for you it's completely underrated our
hunter-gatherer ancestors will walk for
hours a day hours we're not meant to be
sitting down and all day and eat but
even like even doing lots of cardio
workouts and
and CrossFit and just you know I mean
forgetting lean it's not really the way
to do it because typically what happens
is you get hungry after and you burn
great you burn 500 calories you just
worked your ass off you burn 500
calories and you know two things happen
either you going to eat an extra 500
calories that day or more or you try to
stick to this to your deficit but
because you burn those fabric calories
now you're ravenous and now oh [ __ ] now
you're feeling now you now you give in
now you feel guilty now you're binge
deep you know you've been cheating so
you know I I actually just recommend
honestly just walking if you want to go
and do some activities from cardio go go
box go play a sport get off the
treadmill running on a treadmill for an
hour as well that's what I say
so I actually find that the I guess
what's all fleeing down just strength
training and walking and you know if you
want to go do sprints or little jump
trouble a boxing session here and there
you can but it's more so for fun and
just for fitness it's not necessary tell
people this way like doing doing Tom
trying to burn calories from running to
lose weight it's just not it's not that
effective it's not as good even is it's
not even a good use of you you know it's
not even a good use of you tonight
so to go do that stuff for other reasons
but calorie deficit to lean down and
walking just because it's awesome it's
great for you you can listen to podcasts
you while you're happier and and and so
yeah it's it's diet but again you could
be working out four to three hours a day
and and gain weight if you are eating
too much yeah fair people believe if
people don't believe this well what
happens when you're sick you're not
moving much you lost your appetite do
you lose weight eating anyway you know
yeah so yeah precisely okay well I'm
gonna wrap up that was very interesting
I think we should do this again in the
future later there were a whole bunch
more questions but I'm keep
these things too about an hour okay last
question last question a couple of
people asked this is how do you feel
about my all steak diet what are your
thoughts you know what I automatically
person and I respect it obviously this
this style of eating with your
autoimmune condition is the best way to
go and for other people of course and so
ultimately what matters is finding that
approach that's gonna that's gonna you
know solve your problems help you
achieve your goals and in that you know
and so absolutely you know that's the
way to go for me I like my potatoes my
chocolate so I you know it'd be fun for
me to do an experiment of going full on
you want to fall on carnivore I I I do
find though for me with with you know I
do find that I do like my carbs I do
like I'm like a balanced guy I love my
steak I love my I want everything I want
the steak I want the potatoes you know
yeah for you to like you're already do
you have anything you'd need to solve
like you have enough muscle to that
you're probably effectively using carbs
if your your muscles problem might
actually benefit from the added carbs
and if you don't have any other health
problems then other aspects of health
outside of nutrition and exercise and
supplementation osan supplements or
outside of supplements how you know
emotional repression or stress or other
these other aspects interplay with
health the earth of your found any sort
connection there with like you know
stress levels or other things affecting
yeah a bit like nothing like diet diets
just been so big
it basically solved all of my problems
it was insane
I've done you know meditation and if
you're under enough stress then you get
like psychologically sick ish but for me
anyway I've never gotten as sick as I
was with diet like even stress from my
parents getting ill like my mum and dad
both my mom and dad almost died in the
last year and it was like I went kind of
crazy with stress but I didn't go as
crazy as I was
Wow with diet yeah so know it like
nothing's really nothing's really been
the same as diet yeah how many and just
curiously just curiosity so what is he
how much like meat are you eating a day
is it like two and a half pounds of beef
oh god no no the longer I'm on this
honestly the longer I'm on it
the more calories matter so when I first
started it and I switched over to meat I
was eating like two and a half pounds a
day which is way over what I need to eat
and I still lost weight like for six
months and then once my body kind of got
used to it it was like if I overeat meat
all gain weight and if I under eat it
I'll lose weight so yeah for anybody
listening who is trying to figure out
why they're not losing usually that's
the question why why are they doing the
carnivore died and not losing weight its
calories still do matter but for some
reason for the first like three to six
months a lot of people especially if
they have a lot of extra weight to lose
will still lose weight even if they're
eating you know two and a half or three
pounds of meat a day but that does stop
eventually and so you're doing like a
powernow yeah like a pound to a pound
and a half and I'm generally like trying
to do one meal a day or I actually find
it easiest doing a small meal and then a
bigger meal yeah that's the most yeah
see like a six ounce steak and I'm like
a like a fourteen or something or twelve
something like something like that yeah
carnivore I'd be on
like three pounds of steak a day three
pounds yeah yeah that's a lot of steak
but you know but maybe if I could've
found your steak like a ribeye I just
didn't - yeah true true that's that's
the things that if you do go carnivore
you know you got it you got to make sure
you get like you know you got to get
that you can't go too low in fats you to
get those rib eyes and stuff so yeah
yeah yeah and you're more of a strip
loin person right sorry Morris triple in
value no well I'm gonna mix it up to the
mix with the Bison do it okay where can
people find you yeah so Instagram is
where I'm very active so my Instagram is
Greg o Gallagher can find me there and
YouTube
I'm Kino body on YouTube kay Ino body
and and my website is Kino body calm
those are three places to check out but
if you have to go to one place I just
say just connect me on Instagram because
that's where yeah I definitely do
Instagram your Instagram is so much fun
I like it okay well thanks for coming on
Greg I'll link all those links below and
when you have your women's workout
program send it over I would be killed a
transformation workouts okay sounds good
thanks for coming on
[Music]